thank you for talking to me about this i
am having so much fun with the show and
your character in particular
i i also love that this is
a show about two women one being a
disgraced journalist in need of a great
story and then this other young woman
and mother who's convicted of this crime
she says she didn't commit
was that
really sort of one of the most appealing
elements of the story to you was that
something you were looking forward to
exploring especially seeing how it had a
little bit of humor injected into it
it was and then it wasn't i felt a
little sketchy about it you know because
this is the first
it's the first thing i've ever done in
tv and film which is crazy
insane
and i didn't i didn't know whether or
not i wanted that to be folks first
impression of me
so when i was auditioning for the show
and i had read it i was a little iffy
about it i was talking to my manager and
he was like you know what what if we get
you on the phone with the writer so that
you can sort of see what the direction
is for the whole series and when i got
on the phone with rebecca adelman i was
overwhelmed by how much i enjoyed her
and
how much i
connected with the vision of the show
and that it was humorous and
i was hooked
and then i got the part which i was very
overwhelmed by and uh yeah that element
of me being an incarcerated woman and
this disgraced journalist and us trying
to it's like a thelma louise sort of
situation but
probably worse because we just can't
seem to connect
uh
it was very interesting to me and it all
came to life when we started shooting
and i was thrilled from then on
yeah i love how she's sort of got to
rely on this woman who is just a
complete mess
and
it's sort of not the person you'd want
to have to rely on to like you know come
through in such a big way
no i
and tony questions it the entire time
you know and i even think the audience
will question it too it's like you know
why are you with this woman she's such a
mess and tony's a bit of a mess too
where it's like you know i have my
things together
but for some reason i just keep going
back to her i don't know why i keep
choosing her but yeah
what have you liked about her as a
character and about playing her from day
one are there things that you just once
you stepped into her were there things
that you just really enjoyed about her
i loved her sense of humor i loved
how unabashedly herself she is tony um
i love her interests you know when i was
collaborating with rebecca adelman
i was like you know what if what if
she's in the anime or what if she's into
what if she's into these things that you
wouldn't necessarily associate with a
black woman who's incarcerated and that
was a lot of fun for me and i was also
invited into the writers room to kind of
give those suggestions as well
and i love how funny tony is it's like
how funny you are being locked up and
having a sense of humor about this woman
who's making a mess of trying to figure
out a way for you to get out
is
is really interesting and requires a lot
of trust she's she she um even though
she's skeptical of beth she trusts her
to it to a degree so
yeah i loved all of those aspects of
playing tawny
i loved it because this story does run
that risk of dipping into a white savior
story
then it does point that out it addresses
it pretty early on was that something
that you also thought was important that
it it does it says something it says you
know we know what that this is
what we might be seen as so we're going
to say it before you think it
say it before you think it i that was
one thing i was so impressed by with
rebecca was how bold and brave she is
she was like i want to bring in these
topics and i don't want to shy away from
them and i want her to be a mess a
disaster like
beth burgess's character
and i wanted to i mean but that's the
world that we live in and it's one the
one thing that i admire about rebecca is
she wants to call those things out and
for folks to even talk about it too like
we're talking about it now but like you
know in in a world of being politically
correct and cancel culture and all that
stuff
you do shy away from bringing up topics
like that but i think that's what makes
this piece very uh
very good
yeah especially when we all live in a
world now where we know what to call it
it's hard not to address it it seems
less true when you're not saying like i
recognize this is the situation
and it's funny that seeing where she is
called out and pop by
i always giggle because she had no idea
she was like yeah i know but she they're
like no but do you really know
and uh
i love that it was a group of
yeah a group of individuals who are
younger than her trying to school her so
that she doesn't make a fool of herself
very funny
yeah did you care whether or not your
character really did what she's been
accused of was that something like
whether or not she's really guilty
was that something you even cared to
have a definite answer on is that
something that mattered
to you or was it more about
how
this position she's in affected and
changed her
it didn't matter to me because i
believed that i was innocent i mean i
you know especially as an actor you have
to play what it is that your character
is saying and it's like no i'm innocent
period
and i
and i loved like i did get all the
scripts but i tried my best to just read
each script as we were
shooting i did read all of them at once
but as we were shooting i wanted to
really get into the mindset of what my
character was doing right then and there
and it's like if i'm innocent right then
and there that's where i'm at and i
believed it and so
i can't wait for people to see whether
or not i am innocent or guilty i'm not
i'm actually interested to find out too
because it's been so long since we shot
it
but yeah the um
it didn't it it mattered to me but then
it wasn't my sole focus there was a lot
of other things to focus on
i mean i'm believing her at least in the
first three episodes and i don't know
what might happen along the way but i'm
certainly i'm feeling for her so
thank you for feeling for her no things
change up and also that's part of tony's
character too is
her survival it's like i'll play to the
right people who are in front of me and
then when you're gone i have other
things going on
i love what you're doing on the show and
with this character and as a newcomer to
hollywood what's it like for you to
step into this role take on a 10 episode
series have a high profile co-star like
kate beckinsale what are you learning
about it all
everything
everything
and i am not afraid to say i don't know
i don't know what's going on
um you know i'm i'm you know juilliard
definitely prepared me for this and that
like when you have a question ask a
question
um and
i also know how to prep as an actor i
know i'm a good actor i believe in
myself
and you know i'm also a spiritual person
so i just i'm accepting the gift of this
10 episode series and
i just believed i believed that i could
get it done and they believed in me too
so it's overwhelming but
i can do it i know i can do it
and i did it so
and here we are doing this press junket
first press junket ever it's you know
all of it is very overwhelming but
i can do it i believe in myself
where do you hope it takes you next i
mean have you thought about the kinds of
projects you want to do are there
specific types of roles you want to play
or any
person like in history you'd like to
take on i've been looking at historical
figures lately like
uh audrey lord i've always wanted to do
like a biopic of her and blame her
um
i would love to continue to do theater
it is my first love so doing a show on
broadway has always been i've done an
off-broadway show but i'd love to do a
broadway show
and you know i have little things that i
want to do like right now i'm shooting a
period piece and that is something i
never thought i would do
and i think
also trusting that like when the right
project appears like i'm going and i'm
one of the you know and i want to do it
so
i have visions of things that i want to
do but you know life is long and
hopefully i'll have a career a long
career and
um i'll get to make projects that i've
always wanted to make
and it's cool that you get to do drama
and humor and this so that people can
see both sides of that as well
yeah yeah no
i'm grateful for this show for sure well
awesome i appreciate you talking about
it i'm so excited to take the journey
with her and see where she ends up
well me too but
thank you thanks a lot